- Thanks, Priya, and thanks for having me.
I'm really honored to be here.
So I'm a philosopher of science,
interested in causation
and causal modeling.
I work on both sort of
fairly concrete issues
about the nuts and bolts
of causal modeling,
but also on sort of much more abstract
and high level issues
about the foundations of causal inference,
and how causation and causal inference
sort of fits in a physics
based picture of the world.
And so today, my talk's gonna
be much more in the abstract,
high level side.
It's gonna be fairly disconnected
from the day-to-day methodological issues
that you might face in science.
But essentially what I'm gonna focus in on
is this phenomenon that
has puzzled physicists
and philosophers of
science for a long time,
which is that in some sense,
it's easier to infer the
past than the future.
I'm going to try to tell a story
as to why that's the case,
that I think brings out
some interesting facts
about causal inference and
how the physics of our world
puts constraints on the
kinds of causal inferences
we can make about the past or the future.
So, what do I mean when I say
that it's easier to infer
the past than the future?
I'll tell you in a minute,
if I can find a way to move my slides.
All right.
So, what do I mean when I say
it's easier to infer the
past than the future?
Well, I can give you a couple
of perfectly mundane examples
to get to see what I mean.
You know, if you want to figure out
what the weather was like exactly
10 years ago in New Haven,
you can of course consult
the weather records,
but it's impossible to predict
what the weather is gonna be like
in exactly 10 years from now.
If you see the footprints in your garden,
you can figure out, you know,
a fox visited last night,
but there's no sign in your garden
that tells you a fox gonna
visit tomorrow night.
You know, you can see the dent in the car
and figure out there's
been a collision recently.
But again, no mark on
the car that tells you
the car's gonna be involved
in a collision in the future, right?
So, perfectly mundane examples.
Looking at more interesting
scientific examples,
we have all those
sciences of the deep past,
like cosmology and geology
and evolutionary biology
that give us very detailed
and reliable accounts
of the sometimes very distant past,
but we don't have anything
like a comprehensive scientific account
of the distant future, right?
And so that's the sort of phenomenon
I'm interested in trying to explain,
at a very general level.
And you might think, you know,
the explanation for this sort
of asymmetry of inference,
it's obvious.
It has to do with the
fact that the future,
by definition, hasn't happened yet, right?
So it's still open, and that's
why we can't know about it.
But the past is settled and it's fixed,
and that's why we can
know about it, right?
So there's a couple of issues with that,
but perhaps the most obvious one
is that we do, of course,
make plenty of successful
predictions about the future.
Again, using perfectly mundane
examples to make the point:
we can predict when the next solar eclipse
is going to be in the US.
I can see the smoke rising
from my cooking pan,
and figure out that the
fire alarm is going to beep
in a few seconds, so on and so on, right?
Again, all this is perfectly obvious.
So, the contrast here seems to be really
that when it comes to making
successful predictions,
we're sort of restricted
to very special context,
like context having to
do with isolated systems,
like in a solar system example,
or with the immediate future,
like in my cooking pan example.
Or we can perhaps make predictions
about the longer term future,
but they have to be sort of
very broad brush, very vague.
Like I might predict that, you know,
the Russian invasion of
Ukraine is gonna have
drastic consequences on
the European geopolitics
in 10 years, but might not be able
to make any more specific
predictions than this.
But when we turn to
inferences toward the past,
there's no such restriction, right?
Again, we can make very
detailed, very precise inferences
about sometimes the very distant past,
and about systems like
the weather or species,
that are not at all isolated
from their environment
and whose dynamics may be in
fact quite chaotic, right?
And the point is blunt
distinction between an open future
and a fixed past is not going to be able
to explain that contrast, right?
So presumably, instead, the answer
for why it's easier to infer
the past than the future
has something to do with the
physics of our world, right?
It has to have some sort
of physical explanation.
But that's somewhat of a mystery here,
because the answer or the explanation,
it's not going to come from the
fundamental laws of physics,
because the fundamental laws of physics
are all time symmetric.
They don't really distinguish
between the past and the future.
You know, we've known since Newton
that there's no real intrinsic
direction of determination
in the laws of physics.
Earlier states of the world
determine later states
just as much as later states
determine earlier states.
So, in relativity theory, for example,
you know what's gonna happen at time zero,
here it's gonna be fixed
by the cross-section
in the backward light cone,
but it's also going to be fixed
by the cross-section in
the future light, right?
So there's no asymmetry here.
And so, that means,
you know, from the perspective
of the laws of physics,
there's no real reason
to expect the future
to be harder to predict than the past.
So, there's this mystery
that has puzzled physicists
and philosophers of science
for a while.
Some of the people in this room
have worked on this as well.
Here is some of the relevant literature.
The starting point of all of this
was Hans Reichenbar's work
in The Direction of Time.
Now, one idea you find in Reichenbach
is that this asymmetry has
to do with entropy increase,
and with the second law of thermodynamics.
So, there's a very sort
of influential tradition
of exploring that line of thought.
There's also an idea
you find in Reichenbach
that the asymmetry of inference
has something to do with causation,
and with the distinction
between causes and effects,
and with what Reichenbach called
the principle of the common cause.
So that's more the line of thought
I'm interested in exploring today,
and what I'm going to
say sort of systematizes
some of the things that
Reichenbach says in his book,
but that I think people haven't
really picked up on too much
in this literature.
And so, the big picture
is something like this.
The kinds of inferences
we make toward the past
and toward the future,
they are and they have
to be causal inferences.
They have to involve cause
and effect reasoning, right?
So inferences toward the past,
they almost always involve
deriving the past cause
from a present effect, right?
Only a fox could have
caused those footprints.
You know, only an organism
with this and that feature
could have produced a fossil
that's in front of me,
and so on.
And inferences we make toward the future,
they involve deriving a future
effect from a present cause.
The smoke rising,
that's going to cause
the fire alarm to beep.
The Russian invasion,
that's going to cause
this and that consequence 10
years down the line, and so on.
It's no surprise, of course,
that all the inferences we make
with the past or the future are causal,
because, you know, to infer
an event from another one,
there needs to be some kind
of correlation between them.
And correlation is usually
at least going to require
some sort of causal connection
between those two events.
And so, the hypothesis here
is that maybe there's something
about the cause effect distinction
that makes it easier to
infer the causes of events
than their effects.
Maybe there's something about
the cause effect distinction
that makes it easier to
infer causes from effects,
than to infer effects from causes.
And I apologize for the
mismatch in the slide.
This wasn't like that on my computer.
Of course, to make good
on that hypothesis,
you're going to need to explain
what exactly distinguishes
causes from effects.
And you know, why that distinction
would sort of give rise
to this asymmetry.
And that question,
the distinction between
causes and effects,
that's also something that
has puzzled physicists
and philosophers of
science for a long time.
Again, because the
fundamental laws of physics,
they're not really causal.
They don't really distinguish
between past and future.
They don't have a
direction of determination.
So that's sort of a mystery
as to how something like a
robust cause effect distinction
emerges from physics.
And like many people, I think,
the answer at the end of the day
comes from the work done in
the causal model in tradition,
which itself systematizes
some ideas of Reichenbach.
And the thought here,
and I assume this is
familiar to everybody,
is that the kinds of
causal structure we see
in our environment,
they can be represented in
the form of asical graphs
that represent relationships
of direct causation
between variables.
And the sort of key principle,
or the key assumption is
that there are going to be
some principles that relate
to the causal structure of those systems
to the statistical structure.
And the most important one is
the causal mark of condition,
that tells you that exogenous variables,
sort of initial causal conditions,
the causal inputs to your system,
they're not gonna be
correlated with one another.
The values are going to
be fixed independently.
Sorry, in the model over here,
S is not gonna be correlated with W.
But by contrast, endogenous variables,
the effects of the system,
they can and usually are
correlated with each other,
at least when they have
a common cause, right?
Common causes are going
to create correlations
between effects.
So X and Y, for example, here,
are going to be correlated
because they have a common cause.
So, at a very general level,
that's what the cause
effect distinction is about.
It's about causes are the variables
that tend to be statistically
independent of one another,
and therefore are sort of the
causal inputs of the system.
And the effects are those variables
that are correlated with one another.
And what I want to try to
suggest in the rest of the talk
is that it is that
asymmetry, the causal mark,
or the asymmetry encoded in
the causal mark of condition
that explains why it's easier
to infer causes from effects
than vice versa.
And the claim a bit
more precisely is this:
the causal mark of
condition is going to entail
in a number of circumstances
that the probability of an effect,
given a single one of its
causes, is going to be very low,
except if you're in a special context
where, you know, you're dealing
with an isolated system,
or again, the effect is in the
immediate future of the cause
or something like that.
But by contrast, because
the causal mark of condition
doesn't require effects to be
independent of one another,
it allows for correlations between them.
It's going to entail that
the probability of a cause
given its effect can be very high,
even if the cause is in the
very, very distant past.
And even if the system we're dealing with
is not isolated at all.
I'll give you an example
to try to sort of make this
a bit more concrete in a second.
But one other idea I wanna
put on the table here
is that when you think
about causal inferences
and inferences to the
future or to the past,
there's a kind of mystery
of how limited beings like
us can ever infer anything
about the past or the future,
because the physics of
our world seems to put
a lot of obstacles to that.
The problem is that the
dynamical laws of physics
that govern our world, they're global,
in the sense that they relate
global states of the universe.
So again, in relativity theory,
to figure out what happens
at a space and point,
you need information about
the entire cross-section
of the light cone.
Is it backward or forward?
And, you know, typically
that's going to be
an enormous spatial region, right?
And of course we can't
observe global states, right?
We have to make do
with very localized and
partial observations.
So, it's kind of a
mystery of how we can use
those local observations to ever predict
or retrodict what happens
at other times, right?
Even this sort of drastic
under-determination.
And the thought here is going to be
that the causal mark of condition,
or the causal structure of our world,
it removes that obstacle.
It makes it possible to make
inferences from local events,
but it's going to remove that obstacle
more towards the past
than towards the future,
as I might say.
There's still gonna be,
you know, an enormous
epistemic predicament
in trying to figure out
what the future is like.
And a remark for the
philosophers in the room:
I mentioned as this was a line of thought
about, you know, the
asymmetry of inference,
that this has to do with
entropy increase and so on.
The best version we
have of this story today
is due to David Albert.
And you might be wondering,
"What's the relationship here?"
Maybe I'll say a few words
about this at the end
if I have the time.
But very roughly the idea
is that the two stories
are sort of compatible and complementary,
but there are also some important nuances
about, you know, how central
the causal asymmetry is
in the picture of the world,
and how temporal asymmetry
emerged from physics.
I'm just going to work
through an example here
to sort of try to make good
on those various claims
I've made here.
It's not gonna be a
very interesting example
of, you know, historical
scientific inference.
You know, I'm a philosopher.
I use mundane examples because
they help make the points
more simply.
But the idea is, you know,
this is an example we can use to think
about inferences at
other times in general,
including the sort of very
sophisticated inferences
you find in evolutionary
biology and geology, and so on.
So what you have here on
the left is The Mayflower
departing from Plymouth in
England to America in 1620.
And here on the right is a random plaque
I found on the internet
in Harwich in the UK,
that commemorates the departure
of The Mayflower in 1620.
It says a number of things,
but one thing it says is that
this here happened, right?
And obviously there's
a causal relationship
between those two.
So, you know, even if you know nothing
about The Mayflower or anything,
as long as you read English, you know,
you can walk by that plaque, read it,
and then come to learn that
this event happened, right?
If you go around reading plaques,
you'll get it right most of the time.
Plaques are really reliable.
So it's very, very easy to
make that inference here
from the effect to the cause.
But of course, you know,
nobody who had witnessed this here
would've been able to predict
the existence of the plaque
four centuries later, right?
If you had predicted that
you would've been insane.
So, that's a case where, you know,
if you want to put it
in terms of probability,
is the probability of the
effect given the cause
is very high.
Sorry, the probability of
the effect given the cause
is very low, but the
probability of the cause
given the effect is very high.
So again, I want to think about it.
What explains this at a
very general abstract level?
What explains this asymmetry here?
When you looking first at the
cause to effect direction,
it's obvious why nobody would've predicted
the existence of the plaque
four centuries later,
if they had witnessed the
departure of the ship, right?
Because the departure of the ship
obviously was not causally sufficient
for the existence of the plaque.
'Cause staggeringly large
number of other factors
had to be in place in 1620
to later lead to that event, right?
So that includes, you know,
all the factors that would
later make The Mayflower
or its departure a significant
event in world history.
So, you know, facts about the weather
that would ensure that
the ship doesn't sink
and gets forgotten, you know,
facts about the Wampanoag people
who would provide assistance
to the ship's passengers
in Massachusetts and so on.
And also facts that would later lead
to the emergence of plaque
making as an important practice
of memorialization in the 19th century,
and so on and so on.
And of course, you know,
there's a clear sense
in which those factors all
lining up in the right way,
there was enormously unlikely, right?
And that's why just witnessing
again that event here
would not have let you predict this.
And I think there's a general story here
as to why it's so hard to
predict events in the future,
especially the distant
future, from their causes.
If you observe an event C here
that's later going to produce an event E,
whether E is going to happen,
that's also going to depend
on many other causal factors.
And if the event is in the distant future,
often you're going to
need an enormous amount
of such factors,
and the probability that they're going
to line up in the right way,
it's going to be very low.
And that's why observing the causal arm,
that's not going to tell you
that the effect happened.
The probability of that
is going to be very low.
And so, one lesson here
is that I mentioned
this epistemic predicament that we face,
that we can only make local observations,
but we live in a world
governed by global laws, right?
Well, one idea here is that,
at least when it comes
to predicting the future,
that predicament is very severe, right?
The fact that the laws are global
means that a local cause
is never going to be
sufficient for its effect.
You're always going to need
more factors to entail it.
And that means, you know, to
make a reliable predictions,
you would have to be able
to observe all of this.
But that's going to be spread
over an enormous spatial region.
And of course, you know,
we can't make observations
like that, right?
We're limited to observing
the things around us.
Again, this is highly abstract story,
but I hope it makes sense,
and perhaps it strikes you
as perfectly trivial, even,
hopefully.
Where things get interesting
is if you think about what
happens in the reverse direction,
when you go from effect to cause.
So now, when you're reading the plaque
and learning about this event here,
'cause I said, you know,
here we wanna say intuitively
that the probability of the
cause, given the effect here,
it's very high, right?
But it's sort of a mystery
how that can be the case,
because the global character
of the physical laws
that makes it impossible
to predict the future,
it's also present towards the past.
The global character of laws,
it's a time symmetric feature of the laws.
And what that means
is that, just like a local
cause is never sufficient
for a later effect, given the laws,
likewise, a local event
is never sufficient
for its past cause, given the laws.
The laws are always going to tell you,
whether the cause really happened
depends not only on that local events,
but on what happens in an
enormous spatial region.
Again, to figure out what happens here
on the basis of there,
the laws need information about everything
that happens here, right?
To make this a bit more concrete,
one way to see that, you know,
the case of our little plaque here,
it's not sufficient given
the laws for this to happen
or to have happened,
is to think about all the other effects
of the departure of The Mayflower
that are sort of scattered
in the macro state of the world right now.
So this includes things like, you know,
statements in encyclopedias,
monuments to The Mayflower,
memories in the brains of historians
and school children and so on, right?
And imagine for a second
that all those other records
say nothing about The Mayflower,
or say that it departed at some other date
or something, right?
Well, presumably then the laws would say
the plaque is most likely
the result of a mistake
or prank or something like that.
Right?
Now the laws would say
this past cause never really happened.
So that's one way to see that, you know,
whether this thing really happens,
as far as the laws are concerned,
it depends on what happens
globally over here.
But again, you know, just seeing this here
is enough to make the inference.
So, that's sort of a mystery again.
And this is again a general feature.
There's nothing specific about my example.
Whenever you see a local effect E,
and you're trying to predict
a past cause C of it,
well, whether C really happened,
as far as the physical laws are concerned,
that's also going to depend
on all the other effects of C.
And if all those other effects are absent,
or if they say something different,
then the laws are going to tell you
C most likely didn't happen, right?
So, the upshot here is that we have
this sort of deep symmetry
at the physical levels
between cause to effect inference,
and effect to cause inference, right?
And the question is, "What
breaks the symmetry?"
What makes it so that here,
the probability of the effect
given the cause is very low,
but here, the probability of
the cause given the effect,
it can be very high.
But I think if you think about it
in terms of causal modeling,
and the asymmetry between
causes and effects
that's encapsulated in the
causal mark of condition,
then the answer becomes clear.
In a causal mark of condition,
it's going to tell you,
looking first at the sort
of cause to effect case,
those variables here, C
and D are the causes of E.
They're exogenous variables, right?
So the causal mark of condition tells you
there's not going to be
any correlation between C
and the other causes of the
effect you're trying to predict.
And that's why the probability of E
given that cause alone has to be very low.
One way to say this is simple,
that C was correlated with
all those other conditions,
X1, X2, and so on.
Then the simple occurrence of C
would make those conditions very likely,
and therefore the occurrence of E
also very likely as well, right?
So here, just observing C
would provide a lot of information
about what's going to
happen in the future.
That's precisely the sort of correlation
between exogenous
variables that's forbidden
by the causal mark of condition.
In the case of The Mayflower,
the causal mark of condition says
you're not going to find a correlation
between, say, the departure
of a ship from a harbor,
and all the other conditions required
to make that departure
memorable four centuries later.
And that's why just observing
the departure of the ship
doesn't make the effect likely at all.
And the reason that this
doesn't apply in reverse
is that here, now, we
are dealing with effects
of a common cause, right?
The effect you're observing
and all the other effects of C,
they're the effect of a common cause.
And here, the causal
mark of condition says,
you know, those things can and
generally will be correlated
with one another.
And that means the probability
of C, even E alone,
again can be very high.
All that this requires is that
there be a strong correlation
between E and the other effects of C.
That's all that's required
for this thing over here
to make that thing very likely.
So if you think of it
in terms of my example,
again, plaques generally
make the events they report
very likely, right?
Plaques are reliable in general.
If you go around reading plaques,
you're gonna get it
right most of the time.
How can that be, given that
the events they report,
as far as the laws are concerned,
also depend on many other things
in the macro state of the world?
Well, the answer is that
the content of those plaques
is strongly correlated with other records
of those past events,
of, you know, memories in
the brains of historians,
monuments, what encyclopedias
say and so on, right?
So that's why you don't need
to consult the encyclopedias
or ask the historian and so on, right?
Just reading the plaque is enough.
So the upshot here is
that if that's right,
it's really the causal mark of condition
that explains why we can
infer so much about the past,
but little about the future.
And again, to repeat this one more time,
the background here is
that we face this problem
that the physical laws are global,
but we can only make local observations.
So there's this mystery as to
how we can ever infer anything
from those local observations.
And the thought is the distinction
between causes and effects
explains why that
predicament is really severe
when we try to infer the future,
but it's not so severe when
we try to infer the past.
And the idea is, you know, if
you make a local observation,
if you see a local event over here,
it's not going to be correlated
with all the other causes
of the effects it's going
to produce in the future.
So the observation by
itself doesn't tell you much
about the future, but the
local event you observe,
it's going to be correlated
with all the other effects
of its past causes.
And that's why your
local observation alone
can give you a lot of
information about the past.
I'm not sure how much time I have left.
Priya, Owen, do you know when I started?
- [Priya] Four minutes.
- Four minutes.
- [Priya] If you want Q and A.
- Yeah. Okay.
One thing I like about
the story I've just told
is it explains why we can
sometimes predict the future,
the special context in which
we can predict the future.
These are context where, you know,
one of the principles
that that appeal to me
in explaining why predicting
the future is hard,
one of those principles,
it's not gonna hold.
So when you're dealing with
isolated systems, for example.
Here, you're dealing with a system
where it's future states,
where it's determined by only
a small number of variables.
And the probability that
outside circumstances
are going to disrupt the system
is just very, very low, right?
So just making a few local
observations about the system
is gonna be able to predict
what's going to happen in the future.
But of course, you know,
our lives and economies
and political systems,
the things we're interested in predicting,
they're not isolated systems, right?
What happens in their future,
it always lies in the intersection
of multiple independent causal lines.
And that's why we can't
really predict about them.
Immediate future,
the story, like in my cooking pan example,
where I can predict the
fire alarm's gonna beep
in a few seconds:
the idea here is if the effect
is really in the near future,
there's not much room for other conditions
to make a difference.
So here, local observations
gonna be enough
to predict what's gonna
happen fairly soon.
And then broad brush predictions;
you know, I know that the Russian invasion
is gonna have some
consequences in the future.
I don't know what they are.
Well, the thought here is,
if you predict a very
generic unspecific effects,
the sort of outside conditions
that are required for
that effect to happen,
there're also going to be very generic,
and you can sort of safely
assume they're in place.
So here, you can predict what might happen
in the distant future,
as long as you remain very
vague and very, very unspecific.
A couple of questions. You
know, what about memories?
I haven't really talked about memories
as another way to know about the past
that we can't apply to the future.
There are things to say about this,
but won't say them today.
I'm skipping the second point here.
There's also a question about, you know,
if you think about it in
terms of physics here,
this asymmetry that you find
in the causal mark of condition,
where does it come from?
The thought is it's going to
come at the end of the day
from certain facts about the
initial state of the universe.
Maybe some sort of initial
randomness conditions,
something like that.
So that's how at the end of the day,
you're going to explain, you know,
how time symmetric physics gives rise
to this sort of time
asymmetry of knowledge
and of inference.
Maybe I'll stop here.
I'll just leave, you know,
summary of some of the main points,
and there's a paper,
if you're interested in looking at it.
There's a link over here.
So, thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Priya] Thanks so
much, Thomas. Questions?
- [Audience] Yeah, so I'm a little puzzled
whenever I hear this kind of thing,
because the examples seem
to be kind of cherry picked,
and I can cherry pick
them the other direction.
Of course, you've got systems.
To make any predictions, they
have to be pretty isolated,
'cause if stuff's gonna
come from the outside, okay.
So, let's have a isolated system.
It could have a chaotic dynamics,
then I'm gonna have trouble predicting it,
or could have a dissipative dynamics
and I'm gonna have really
good chance I'll predict well,
and I'll retrodict badly, right?
I have a room and I say,
"All right, it's isolated,
it's been isolated for five minutes.
It's gonna be isolated for five minutes.
There's a little ball
sitting on the carpet."
And I say, "In five minutes,
that ball's gonna be sitting
there, right on that carpet."
What was it doing three
minutes ago? Who knows?
Could have been rolling in, right?
'Cause it's friction,
it's gonna dissipate.
So I can predict, well,
I can retrodict badly.
I see the rain outside and I say,
"Well, I can now make a
pretty good prediction
that it will say rain
in the papers tomorrow."
That means from the papers tomorrow,
I can make a good retrodiction
that it did rain today.
From the seeing the rain today,
I can't retrodict what
the papers said yesterday.
I mean, it seems to me there's
no real pattern here at all.
So, I'm not really sure
what even the datum is
that we're supposed to be explaining,
because you can pick
examples that go this way,
and I can pick other examples
that go the other way.
And it has to do with chaotics,
it has to do with dissipation.
There are all kinds of
how stable things are.
I see a plaque, what should
I infer about what happened?
Well, if I'm in 1984, I
have to know a whole lot
about, you know,
is the Ministry of Truth
controlling what's on plaques?
Maybe I can infer from the
plaque that nothing like that.
I mean, maybe I can't infer anything.
So it seems to me the whole situation
is just kind of much more
messy than this suggests.
- Yeah, and I agree with
a lot of what you said.
I still think there is
some sort of difference.
It's very subtle how to
sort of exactly express it.
The best I can do is have this claim
about, you know, there's a sense
in which the context that
our prediction is possible.
There's a sense in which they're special,
or at least, you know,
we can sort of list them.
It's about isolated systems
or the immediate future and so on.
But least when it comes to
inferences towards the past,
there are certain limitations
that don't hold, right?
It doesn't have to be
a bad immediate past,
it doesn't have to be an
isolated system and so on.
And the thought is,
the story here is supposed to
explain why that's the case.
So you can think of the story as saying
there is one obstacle to
predicting the future.
It has to do with the globality
of the laws of physics.
Why isn't that obstacle an
obstacle to inferring the past?
Well the answer is
something about causation.
But of course that doesn't
mean we can infer everything
about the past.
We can't retrodict the
trajectory of the ball.
There's gonna be plenty of situations
where there's just limits
to what we can retrodict.
What's gonna be the explanation for that?
Well, I don't think there's gonna be
sort of a general physical explanation.
At this point, you know,
it's gonna be case by case.
In the case of plaques, you know,
has to do with the sort of
social practices we have
and why there's no
Ministry of Truth so on.
In the case of footprints,
it's going to be something
about thermodynamics
and human anatomy and so on.
So there's gonna be lots
of little local stories,
but if there is something global to say,
I think it's something like what I said.
- If I may ask?
- Sure.
- Take the prerogative,
to ask it.
So, I'm slightly confused,
so I want a clarification.
Is one of the issues that
predicting the future state
is sort of handicapped by
the lack of information?
It's not about the laws,
but the lack of information
of the full list
of relevant causes.
So it's incomplete
information about causes
that may become relevant in the future,
which we cannot enumerate
at the present time
with local observations.
- Absolutely.
- Okay.
- But the thought is if
you look at the physics,
you can get in a mood
where that also applies
towards the past,
and you know, the information I have,
it's also in a sense very incomplete,
to retrodict the past,
because you know, the
laws of physics tell me,
it also depends on what happens
in this enormous region.
- This is of course,
we are speaking about everything
in terms of deterministic-
- Yeah. Yeah.
- When wading into probabilistic domains.
- Right, of course.
- [Audience] Thank you. Very inspiring.
My question relates to
the previous questions.
The first one is the way
that you've been using laws,
and global laws for me seems to,
and maybe you can confirm this,
that you have a very reductionist logic,
so that The Mayflower as a
phenomenon is a set of laws,
or is due to a set of laws of physics,
which for me yeah, if that's correct,
I'm curious to know
if that's an explicit assumption for you.
And the other one which I'm interested in
is about the plaque,
and why is the plaque something
that we should infer the
existence of The Mayflower from?
Because if I understand
your story correctly,
that what is happening in this asymmetry
is that the effects are correlated,
and because of this correlation,
we have this asymmetry,
and the causes, they're not correlated.
So that's why it's harder
to go to the future
than go to the past.
So then, why does a single
plaque have the authority
or the capability of showing you
that this Mayflower should exist?
If you're saying that, why
is it not a set of effects
that make that we can go back to the past
easier than that we can go to the future?
Is it not something in the plaque
that makes that there was
already a set of correlations happening?
The thing that you said
about some social phenomenon,
that this plaque is made
in certain conditions,
or the fact that if we want
to actually understand The Mayflower,
and that we're not in
some Disneyland plaque
that says something about
the existence of Captain Hook
and his ship,
and that we need these
type of correlations
to actually do that.
- I forgot the first question.
- It was about your logic
and your reductionism.
- Yeah. All of this.
There are all sorts of
reductionistic assumptions
in place here.
Sort of, I guess, common
ground in that debate.
So otherwise, you know, The Mayflower,
that's a physical system.
It's at the end of the day governed
entirely and ultimately
by the physical laws.
And so there's a mystery
as to explaining how,
in terms of the laws of physics,
you know, we can make certain
inferences about the system,
but not others.
So yeah, very large scale
assumptions in place here.
The second one, I mean,
not sure what to say here.
One thing, you know, this
is a specific example,
and of course there's gonna
be very specific things
to say about why plaques
are reliable and so on.
But the point here is to try to tell
a much more abstract and general story,
and you know, to put it
in those abstract terms.
We find very strong correlations
between things in the present
and things in the past.
We find few correlations
between things in the present
and things in the future.
And we qualify that in all
sorts of ways, and so on.
And it is, you know, the
physics of our world,
it seems to prevent the
correlations anyway,
in whatever direction.
The thought is, you know,
it's the causal structure of the world
that explains the solution.
Then after that, you know,
if you want to explain why are plaques
specifically very strongly correlated
with the events they report,
well again, it's gonna be a local story
about human practices and you know,
why the people who
commissioned the plaques,
they have an interest in
having reliable ones and so on.
But the point is to have this
sort of much more abstract,
much more general story on the table.
- [Priya] (indistinct) and then.
- [Audience] Yeah, thanks
so much for your talk.
So, I'm totally on board
with understanding the causal asymmetry
in terms of this probabilistic asymmetry.
And I was curious whether you
see as part of your project,
as trying to say something
about why those
asymmetries get manifested,
given the way the universe is.
So, even given everything you've said,
if you did not have independent causes,
then you know, it would
trivially be true, but unhelpful.
Causal marker would apply.
You couldn't use it for anything.
And it seems to me,
there are sort of ongoing
debates about this.
So, I had taken the story
as someone like Dan Hausman says,
I mean he appeals basically
the same asymmetry,
and he would say, you know,
that there's no causation in
closed deterministic systems,
so it's only when we coarse grain
and consider sort of open subsystems.
And it seemed to me that
orientation of your talk
went in that direction.
Mattias Frisch disagrees.
So, I'm curious whether
this is part of your project
to then say something about that.
- Yeah, good, thanks. Thanks.
I'm more on the side of
the causal asymmetry.
It sort of emerges when you
are coarse graining the system,
and you get probabilities, and so on.
As you mentioned,
this is something on which
people have had a lot say,
and I don't have much more to add to this.
This is sort of the
background. You're right.
But I think, you know,
if you think about the causal asymmetry
in totally different terms,
as this sort of fundamental
arrows there is in the world,
perhaps people who have sort
of more robust metaphysics
are inclined to think of it that way.
You can also tell that story, I think.
- [Priya] Last question.
Okay, we have two.
Peter and (indistinct).
- [Peter] So, I wonder what extent,
really reflecting whatever-
- [Speaker] Sorry, you have to-
- [Peter] I was pressing
it, then I wasn't.
- [Speaker] Yeah, you don't have to-
- [Peter] Only press it once, right.
Excuse me, I haven't
gathered that obviously.
So, it feels as if the
history is very protected
in the case of The Mayflower.
It really takes an effort
of will over centuries
for the plaque to exist.
And if something is forgotten,
then refinding it can be a huge effort.
And if an effort of will is imposed
to deliberately forget,
so a criminal wants an
act not to be remembered,
then the will to forget it
becomes a very serious part
of whether it is remembered,
whether it is a commemoration.
So how would you see willpower,
just the will, the human
will, figuring into this?
- That's interesting. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're absolutely right
here that, you know,
in this example there's a lot to say
about human practices of
memorializing certain events
and not others.
Yeah.
I don't have anything sort of
insightful to say about this.
The idea is, you know, at a certain level,
The Mayflower thing,
you could use examples
that have nothing to do
with human action and human
practices to tell the point.
This falls all over there.
You know, it's a sign of the
existence of the species,
millions or billions of years ago.
But physics tells me whether
that species really existed,
it depends on not only the
existence of that fossil,
but actually the entire cross-section
of the forward light cone, right?
And of course there's perhaps not gonna be
any other macroscopic
signs of the existence
of that species.
Maybe the fossil is the only
macroscopic record we have,
but at the macroscopic levels, you know,
there's still gonna be correlations,
and as far as how is that possible?
You know, how is it possible
for the fossil to still
provide information
if that's the case.
- [Priya] Harry.
- [Harry] Hey, thank you
for all the great talk.
So what I want to ask is that,
certainly at the Newtonian level,
there is time reversal
symmetry in the laws,
but at the quantum filter
theory level, would there be?
Because CPT is preserved,
and we know by matter
antimatter, CP is violated,
so time reversal wouldn't hold
at the quantum filter theory level.
So maybe that leaves any perspective
of how this asymmetry might arise?
- This is a great question,
and I have absolutely nothing to say.
- [Harry] Actually,
the cosmologists might.
- This is outside of my area
of not complete incompetence, I guess.
And I wish somebody who was knowledgeable
about those issues would answer.
I guess one thing to say is, you know,
the sort of inferences we make,
they're based on microscopic phenomena
and at the microscopic level,
I assume the dynamics is,
it's kind of quasi deterministic, right?
So I'm perhaps skeptical
that going to the fundamental levels
is going to sort of tell you
or provide the answer here.
Because again, you know,
whatever asymmetry you're going to find,
it doesn't really seem to percolate up.
But again, you know, I don't
know much about those issues.
- [Priya] I let (indistinct)
make a quick comment.
- [Audience] I mean, I
can answer that question.
You might worry, in quantum theory,
if you've got a fundamental
collapse theory,
a fundamentally indeterministic theory.
Then you might be able to
predict and not retrodict.
But CPT has nothing to do with it,
because as long as you obey CPT,
there's gonna be information preservation
at the global scale in both directions.
That's not gonna break.
That'll be perfectly symmetric.
From perfect information at any time,
you can get perfect
information at any other time.
- [Audience] You can say that
information is not preserved
in quantum theory.
- Yeah, but the time reversal,
you said the time reversal was broken,
the relevant time reversal isn't.
Relevant time reversal is the preservation
of information in both directions.
- [Priya] Great. Thanks
once again, Thomas.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)